let me ask
sort of a critical question of if you're
wrong about your statements of about
bitcoin
you find out years from now that you
were wrong
what would that look like what would be
the things that make you realize you
were wrong
likely ideas or crazy out there ideas
do you think about this kind of stuff
all the time
because you speak very confidently about
bitcoin and one of the things
let me put it this way i think certainty
i feel like that's like a stoic
statement certainty leads to ruin
or something like that like certainty i
think is an
antithesis to progress
often and especially in your writing but
this is true for the bitcoin community
there's a
there's a certainty about the bitcoin
and that makes me very skeptical no
matter how good the ideas are
whenever things are good this might be
the russian in me
i think like what are the ways this is
gonna go wrong
so so what do you think are the ways
this might go wrong or you're wrong
in your conception of what bitcoin is
yeah so science
evolves via negativa meaning that
we're not proving hypotheses
and that's what becomes the body of
science
science is whatever is left over as we
disprove hypotheses
right whatever we can empirically
through experimentation disprove gets
discarded and whatever remains
whatever theory remains that hasn't been
disproven is
science effectively
this process is similar to
market actors zeroing in on a store
value right they're
they're experimenting with different
forms of
uh storing wealth across time uh some do
better than others and eventually
everyone ends up on the one that is best
that's what gold was um in terms of
understanding bitcoin i look at it as a
similar approach
and i'm actually that is the main
question i'm asking myself is how do you
stop this thing how do you turn it off
how do you end it if if you're a nation
state particularly who has the most to
lose in this transition
what is the attack vector by which they
neutralize bitcoin i mean that is the
250 trillion dollar question
and you know i've spent five years
thinking about this thing very deeply
i've read
everything on monetary history i can get
my hands on
the general thought of how it is stopped
and this is this is the snag point that
a lot of people get to
in their explorations down the rabbit
hole is they just say the government
will never allow it
and that becomes kind of their bottom
it's like all right bitcoin's
interesting it's superior money blah
blah blah but the government will never
allow it and they said was uh ray dalio
did he say that dalia was currently
stuck there yeah
so ray dalio said that uh bitcoin seems
to be too promising
yeah uh if if it is in fact as promising
as it looks
uh governments are going to uh i don't
forget what the exact quote is
but not allowed ban it yeah governments
will ban it
so how do you get ray dalio unstuck
from your perspective well and how do
you get unstuck from that idea that
governments
will governments how do you prevent
governments from
stopping a thing that threatens
centralized power
well bitcoin is an idea
so governments that are
really good at fighting
centralized threats to their power right
whether that's a currency counterfeiter
or a competing nation state
or business they don't like or an
individual they don't like
you know they can kill them they can
throw them in gel they can use any
number of course for violent tactics to
suppress it
but how do you point a gun at an idea
how do you how do you coerce an idea
um and that's
you know there's there is some anecdotal
history here where
there's the pgp case which in the united
states
the court was trying to classify it as
munitions when we were shipping this
pretty good privacy software overseas
government wanted to classify it as
munitions and restrict that exportation
but and this was a circuit court case
precedent when
uh the pgp attorneys actually printed
out the source code on paper
and presented it as evidence in the
court all of a sudden it became
protected under freedom of speech
and that it's just code is speech code
is
is language and um therefore at least in
the united states it's protected under
the first amendment
um i think a government
ban would be largely unenforceable
frankly on bitcoin
being that it's pure information if you
suppress market actors from using it in
one jurisdiction you're just creating
incentives for them
to go elsewhere and you're actually
increasing the incentive for other
jurisdictions to be
be favorable towards it because then
they can create they get to benefit from
the tax revenue and the businesses and
the innovation
that's occurring in and around bitcoin
as a result so you don't think
if a particular central bank like in
europe
or united states bans it not maybe using
those terms but in some kind of way
you think there's a that provides a
really strong incentive for the other
big players to enable it that's right
and they're more likely by the way since
and governments know this by the way too
the other thing that causes the
government to shoot itself in the foot
is that if they ban something they
draw a lot of attention to it yeah
people are smart i mean people ask why
why would a government ban it why can't
i use this
so that's kind of typically be the the
last arrow in their quiver
um they may try to ban it if bitcoin you
know really starts to monetize very
quickly and this
the power structures that they impose
today start to dissolve
uh faster than i you know others might
think they will then they might try and
ban it but i think that ban
will be largely unenforceable um they're
more likely to tax it
which they already do tax it um they're
likely to increase taxation of it
uh they would they're likely to try and
make it more white market
by actually tracing bitcoin seeing who
has it
attaching identities to bitcoin
ownership
um and making sure that they're getting
their pound of flush on all the
transactions
it results in but i don't think
the other thing about this is so we saw
the internet out compete intranets
in that the we could say that open
source networks send out compete closed
source networks and there's a really
good reason for this
it's because in a closed source network
there are costs associated with
defending the network itself
so you have to the
network owners the owners of the closed
source network have to expend resources
protecting it
from competitors and they have to expand
resources imposing its rules
because people they're not voluntarily
adopted rules so you actually have to
impose these rule sets
whereas an open source network which is
something much more akin to capitalism
pure in its pure sense these are
voluntarily adopted rules
so all market participants have agreed
and consented to this rule set
so there's no enforcement cost and
there's no turf protection because
anyone can freely enter or exit the open
network
for that energetic reason i think open
networks
out compete close networks typically
and in the digital age that's why i
think open
that's why internet out competes
internet and that's why open source
networks are going to eat closed source
networks so what bitcoin would be
in that lens is the ultimate open source
monetary network
devouring closed source central bank
monetary networks
and i i just don't see how
there's no possibility of unilaterally
stopping bitcoin or destroying it
so then they're more likely to regulate
or tax it
and again the other fallacy here is a
lot of people tend to think of
governments as these singular
indivisible uh
entities like they just move under one
plan but in reality it's a lot of people
right a lot of people with loosely
coupled interests and agendas and
whatnot
uh regulators and and um
others and when they're wearing their
citizen hat
they're going to see this thing
monetizing they're going to be on the
front lines of
um trying to regulate it trying to
control it and i think what's likely to
happen is they're going to start to
adopt it
to buy some of it even as an individual
or possibly even ultimately as
at a central bank or sovereign wealth
fund level as an insurance policy
against its success
and once you start to acquire something
and then you have
a vested economic interest in its
monetization
i think it kind of dissolves any of the
power structures that are arrayed
against it
from the inside so i've written a lot
about this
in a new series called sovereignism
which is based loosely on
a book called the sovereign individual
and that's the general thesis is that
microprocessing technology would devour
our organizational models the most
important of which is the nation-state
so i think we're going into this world
where
coercion and violence is just much less
rewarding
um it you can't the economics of
violence
are declining because of the the low
cost of
protecting property right you can now
protect your monetary property uh in
bitcoin
at orders of magnitude less cost than is
necessary to run a banking network
so it changes the way
uh it changes the way we organize
ourselves and again if we
zooming back to gold as kind of the
original governor to governments
where if they manipulated the money gold
would leave their country
that's why governments have taking con
relatively concerted action to go off
the gold standard
there's a great book on this called the
gold wars um
that that outlines how governments have
been waging a cold war against gold for
the past 50 years
bitcoin sort of uh renews hope for that
free market governor of governments
and that is this digital gold that
governments cannot stop or co-opt
so i think it's something that's why i
think it's such a big deal
is that it is
changing it's a new useful fiction you
might say
a useful fiction that's super ordinary
to the mythology of the nation state
and government as the dominant
institution in the world well i
i hope you're right that uh all forms of
centralized power
start breaking apart naturally so
governments
the more and more power is given to the
individual whatever the technology is
and bitcoin seems to be a promising
technology that empowers that enables
that
that seems to be the trend and that's a
promising trend
from uh at least from a perspective of
somebody who values
this particular biological meat bag
that's full of consciousness i think
bitcoin is exposing the greatest
scam in human history which is political
authority
like who gives anyone the right to be
politically
have political authority over anyone
else people should be free to adopt
the rules and systems and tools that
best suit their needs
and you know that heart that arc of
history we covered earlier where
as socioeconomic systems have become
more
favorable towards individual sovereignty
the more wealthy we have become
the more we have given the individual
we've maximized individual choice
uh the more wealth that society has
created and the more it is out competed
the systems that have come before it the
latest would be you know capitalism
triumphing over socialism
you